joe biden is not taking vladimir putin's
invasion of ukraine lying down no siree
yesterday he got some staff member to
prop him up and in that brief spurt of
relative vigor and lucidity he promised
to rebuke putin push him away from
ukraine he sent a warning to the russian
leader
there is still time to avert the worst
case scenario that will bring untold
suffering to millions of people if they
move as suggested
the united states and our allies and
partners remain open to diplomacy if it
is serious
when all is said and done
we're going to judge russia by its
actions not its words
and whatever russia does next we're
ready to respond with unity
clarity and conviction
we'll probably have more to say about
this as
it moves on i'm hoping diplomacy is
still available thank you all very much
unity
clarity and conviction
joe biden one of the most divisive
presidents in american history a man who
accused mitt romney of trying to put
black people back in chains a man who
just recently called half of the country
neo-nazis he is going to
unite the world
joe biden a man who has not spoken a
proper english sentence since the bush
administration dotting old joe biden is
going to
bring the world together through the
clarity of his soaring logic
and rhetoric joe biden
a man who has reversed every single one
of his most cherished beliefs the moment
that they became politically
inconvenient joe biden the physical
incarnation of an empty
suit
joe biden is going to lead the world on
the clarity of his convictions
if i were ukraine i would start rallying
the troops i'm glad you like that clip
now here's what you got to do
ring that bell subscribe get the
notifications for all the videos that
come out also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
that is the
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-space k-n-w-l-e-s
space
s-h-o-w subscribe leave a five-star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]